[Music]
hi mystery recap here today i'm going to
explain an episode called nose dive from
the british science fiction series black
mirror
spoilers ahead
watch out and take care
the movie sits in a possible near future
scenario in which society is dictated by
a rating system ranging from one to five
stars
in this kind of society each individual
gives a rating to one another depending
on their interactions
the social and economic position that
one has in this kind of society is
determined by that person's overall
rating there are benefits for those with
four and five overall ratings
on the other hand those with one to
three overall ratings receive little to
no benefits
for this reason inside this society one
must always act positively or else they
will get a low score the episode begins
with a woman jogging in a suburban
village while holding a phone
the woman lacey pound is looking at her
phone inspecting what seems to be
postings from other people which she
gives a rating of five stars each
after jogging she looks at the bathroom
mirror and practices all kinds of
giggles and laughs
in her eyes a faint light can be seen
indicating some sort of technology
lacey lives with her brother ryan who
has a lower approval rating than her and
she is eager to move out lacey then
leaves the house to have lunch
outside she buys a coffee with a cookie
as a response she gives the clerk and
everyone else around her a five-star
rating everyone else in turn gives her a
five-star rating as well
lacey can see each person's overall
rating and information through her eyes
and other people can see it as well
including her overall rating of 4.2
stars and other information
she tries the cookie and coffee which
she did not like and takes a picture of
it afterwards which she posted online
despite her not liking both
the picture receives multiple five-star
ratings and her overall rating goes up
slightly she goes to work after that in
the elevator she meets a woman that she
frequently interacts with
however the details of their
conversation are based only on each
other's posts and information which they
could access through their phones and
eyes
after that lacey goes to her table to
work
there she meets a co-worker whose
overall rating is low her co-worker is
giving off free smoothies to raise his
rating
upon taking one and drinking it she
receives low rating
she notices this and decides not to
interact with him anymore
soon she learns that her house is being
bought so she decides to look for a new
more expensive house to live in
she goes to pelican cove in an exclusive
neighborhood it is an expensive place
but she learns that she needs to raise
her 4.2 rating to 4.5 for a discount on
this luxury apartment she also learns
from a consultant that she has to
socialize with people outside her circle
particularly those of higher ratings to
raise her ratings quickly she tries at
first to act friendly to all people but
only receives average ratings
she then sees her co-worker with a low
rating but he cannot enter the building
this time because his low rating does
not qualify
lacey's co-worker asks for her help but
laci ignores him to preserve her rating
later lacey uploads a photograph of mr
rags a ragdoll that she and her
childhood friend made together
her childhood friend naomi sees this
picture which prompted her to contact
lacey naomi informs her that she is
getting married and she wants lacie her
oldest friend to be her maid of honor
which lacy delightedly accepts naomi has
a rating of 4.8 and has many upper-class
friends and lives on an exclusive and
idealistic island
lacey believes if she nails a perfect
mate of honor speech she will be flooded
with enough five-star ratings to pull
her approval up to the 4.5 she needs
her brother finds it strange that naomi
is asking lacy as her maid of honor when
their relationship was not that great in
the past
lacey insists that naomi is her friend
and that her being the maid of honor
would definitely raise her overall
rating because of this lisi prepares for
her speech at the upcoming wedding even
practicing one last time before leaving
for the wedding her brother stops her
wanting her to think about this
obsession with ratings but lacey already
made up her mind
this leads to an argument between them
ending in giving each other a low rating
on the way to the airport lisey receives
low ratings from two incidents dropping
her rating from 4.2 to 4.1
first she accidentally bumps into a
woman holding a cup of coffee spilling
her coffee and second the taxi driver
gives her a low rating for being so loud
while talking in the phone
what is worse however is that her
original flight has been cancelled and
she needs 4.2 rating to get a seat on
another she insists on taking the seat
causing a scene that results in her
overall rating going down
as a precautionary measure the airport
security guard turns her overall rating
to three which would last for 24 hours
additionally she also receives as
punishment a devastating double damage
effect on her rating which means that
all down votes will incur a double
multiplier because she is going to be
late to the wedding she decides to rent
a car
however she has a low rating and cannot
avail of a higher quality car so she has
no other choice but to rent a car of a
much older model
while driving she practices her speech
as the maid of honor but her trip is cut
short when the car needs to be charged
she learns that the car being an old
model needs an adapter to charge because
she cannot charge it she leaves it
deciding instead to walk and hitchhike
because she has a low rating of 2.8 cars
avoid her but eventually a truck stops
by and offers to help at first lacy is
hesitant seeing that the driver has a
low rating but she agrees later on
while driving the truck driver an older
woman asked lacey where she was going
and why she was going there
lacey tells her that she is the maid of
honor in an exclusive wedding the truck
driver tells her that she was once like
her she had an overall rating of 4.6 and
she was always aiming to receive a high
rating in the belief that it will lead
to a good life
however her husband got cancer and she
did everything for her husband even
taking him to an exclusive hospital but
he was rejected because his rating was
deemed not high enough
after her husband died she decided to
become honest with everything learning
in the process that her so-called
friends did not like her honesty that
much so she ended up having a low rating
however she says she feels much freer
without obsessing over ratings
lacey replies that unlike the old woman
who got nothing to lose she still got
something to live for
the trip takes all night and in the
morning lacey is awakened by the truck
driver telling her that they must part
ways because she is heading in another
direction
as a parting gift the truck driver
informs lacey that she placed alcohol in
her bag
then lacey goes to a nearby toilet and
practices her speech again
she overhears two women talking about a
convention to lacey surprise the
convention is near the wedding reception
after pretending that she is heading to
the same convention she takes a ride
with some cosplayers in a van
soon after naomi contacts her again
telling lacey not to go to the wedding
anymore
she has heard that her overall rating
had gone down to two and that she cannot
have someone like that at her wedding
the only reason she invited lacey was
that it would add her ratings
exponentially lacey surprised and
heartbroken by this learns that she is
just a number to naomi likewise naomi
responds that she knew lacy's intention
all along and that is just to accumulate
high ratings in the wedding in actuality
both of them never saw each other as a
friend but rather as a tool to gain
higher ratings
however despite this lacy still wants to
go to the wedding and deliver her speech
to which naomi responds with a stern no
this doesn't stop lacey she decides to
trespass and crash the wedding reception
the cosplayers left her behind after she
tells them that she doesn't know about
the convention at all
she drinks the alcohol that the truck
driver gave her and stops a few cars but
eventually she sees a four-wheeler bike
and borrows it she finally reached the
reception by sneaking at the back but
not before falling into a swamp and
getting dirty after dressing up lacey
all dirty and drunk delivers her speech
to the audience who in response all gave
her a rating of one she reveals that she
wants to be like naomi someone beautiful
with high ratings a good circle of
friends and a good life
she is forcefully removed from the
reception and is afterwards put in jail
the technology in her eyes is removed
and for the first time she sees the
world without any rating of any kind in
the adjacent cell a man is looking at
her lacy tries to check his information
out of habit but of course she sees
nothing as the technology has been
removed from her
the man insults her and lacy replies
with an insult as well
without any fear of rating they insult
each other to their hearts content
the episode ends with both of them
shouting at each other their anger and
frustration eventually turning to
happiness at this newfound freedom
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out
thank you for watching